partez en voyage en afrique et sans
votre passeport
le zoo de thoiry propose chaque vendredi
un dîner dans la réserve africaine une
expérience immersive au plus près des
animaux sauvages
une idée qui a été mise en place pour
compenser les pertes financières dues à
la crise du coronavirus on n'avait plus
droit de faire la restauration à
l'intérieur n'avait plus le droit de
faire ceci faire cela ça permet à thoiry
de se diversifier de faire découvrir
autrement aussi ses activités autrement
ces animaux à une autre par un autre
moment de la journée puisque dans la
journée on peut les voir en voiture on
est rarement aussi proche et là vraiment
vous êtes au contact avec les soignants
qui assure la sécurité pendant tout le
repas le parc l'un des plus vastes
d'europe propose d'abord une visite d'un
des camions en france
les visiteurs sont ensuite déposés dans
une plaine africaine sécurisé pour
l'occasion pour que les visiteurs
puissent dîner en toute tranquillité une
expérience inédite et dépaysante
on sent vraiment complètement autres pas
il pourrait presque se croire en afrique
c'est vraiment génial au menu bafilo
chez poitrine de porc ou encore saumon
decosse le tout accompagné de délicieux
légumes
le chef cuisinier qu'opus botha est un
spécialiste sud africain du pavé qu il
prépare tous les met lui-même pendant
deux blogueurs habitudes et safari le
chef reste pourtant émerveillés par la
beauté du lieu en afrique ça se fait
régulièrement c'est ce que vous disiez
en avait en afrique du sud namibie ont
peut trouver quelque chose comme ça un
peu partout mais ici en france j'ai
pensé tout le monde unique en fait
qu'elle m'ait appelé devant les sites
disponibles par hasard je suis parce que
vraiment je suis blindé jusqu'à la fin
de 2011 et en mai
grâce de cette règle qu'ovide tous mes
événements sera portée et j'allais temps
de faire ça et c'est de la chance chaque
visite dure trois heures et coûte
environ 115 euros pour les adultes
l'expérience est ailleurs à partir de 12
ans si vous êtes intéressé ne perdez pas
de temps car le zoo de thoiry nous
propose ces visites que jusqu'au 11
septembre